all right sergio
sergio tell me about your life tell me
where you grew up well i grew up right
here
by echo park
childhood was normal i guess both my
parents were
alcoholics so um growing up there wasn't
too much supervision you know so i i got
to do like
i mean i got to do whatever i wanted to
stay stay out and
you know they you know they didn't care
or they're just too drunk to care
you know well
besides i would have want to be at home
my dad beat my mom you know
so i you know i um
i joined the gang what age i was
i was still in junior high so i think i
was like 13. yeah
13. and uh which gang head hunters
headhunters yeah that's a hispanic gang
it's a hispanic thing yeah
um and you know i
joined the gang i did what gang members
do
you know
i go to juvenile hall my first time i
got arrested
i was like 15 i get arrested for a
firearm
uh i get out then uh
like a month later three weeks later i
get arrested for for attempted murder
it gets dropped down to assault with a
deadly weapon
i do like a year off for that in
camp juneau camp then at 17. at 17 i i
feel like uh
like i need money you know like i see
all my mother my mother homies like
you know having to steal the cars
whatever and uh
so i wanted money too and uh the easiest
way
i could make money i had a gun so the
easiest way i could make money is
doing robberies and so
um my first robber i remember uh my
first robbery was uh
it was a little caesars those were my my
favorite targets
little caesars or subways because
they're always like hitting like in the
cut they're you know
small little establishments where i
could go by myself and
in and out right and so
i remember the first one i was i did it
it was like
i was nervous at first and then it just
became easy
and then it just became like like too
easy
and it was never a lot of money
five hundred dollars you know 300. yeah
you're getting away i was getting away
with it and
how many did you do countless
yeah wow at 18
um a month after my 18th birthday i get
arrested
for robberies for doing those robberies
i you know i get caught with a gun
they're charging me for robberies i mean
i'm 18 years old i just turned 18 years
old i'm in a county jail
and uh so
i'm fighting my kids my case they uh
they offer me 12 years as a deal as you
know as a deal to take
[Music]
for for the robberies and
i take it uh
so i'm 18 i'm i'm looking at 12 years
for me 12 years at 18
might as well have been life you know
like i was doing the math i was
i'mma get out when i'm 30 30 something
uh so i was
i was there and i wasn't gonna
i was gonna walk on eggshells right so
so
i get to prison and uh
i'm one of those kids there that wants
to like wants to participate you know
i believe i believe in iran
in our and in our
in our step the thing we have
established in prison right uh
our southern hispanics and uh
so you know
i start doing i start you know doing
stuff in prison
um a little stabbings here little
stabbings there
um
ah i see uh
i see uh what am i my my good friends
actually
uh i used to work out with him in the
yard he uh
he has to he you know it's his
tournament it's his turn to
to uh
to go on a mission right to you know
ernest rice or whatever
and so during shower time he it's his
celie
who's actually going to be the victim
right so they go out
and uh and there's a a porter
there's uh they're like janitors right
they're inmates
he's he's uh he calls um
my friend silly and uh
calls him over and when he's walking
over to him
uh my friend he uh he starts you know
stabbing him whatever they both start
stabbing this guy
and the tower he's running showers right
so he's running showers he's doing this
little shower thing
and uh i guess he hears like locomotion
so he comes he runs
uh from where he was that c-section he
runs the b section
with no uh no
it was just
you didn't use i wouldn't even expect it
but he gets the
uh his rifle mini 14 and he shoots
uh my buddy you know he shoots my buddy
in the head
i remember just one second seeing him do
this to
to his cellmate and then the next second
he was just
on the floor and the guard shot him yeah
the guard shot him shot him dave
and it hit and uh my whole time
i had already been in prison four years
so my whole time in prison had been like
that yeah this is fun right but when
when that happened
i was like like
welcome to prison you know like i was it
it finally hit me that
man like [ __ ]
it could happen to me because i i do
that kind of stuff you know
so anyways it
it just gave me something to think about
anyway so
uh you know i continue my my prison term
i'm like five years in i still need like
seven years something like that
i'm in my early twenties um
uh so yeah there's uh there's a
this big guy right he he a big homie he
uh
he he asks me for a favor and uh
and those are the kind of guys that you
you're like
this is who you bleed for you know like
they tell you to
do something you do it because you know
they they're the big dogs right so
so i'm like i'm i'm like yeah yeah yeah
uh i'm flattered or whatnot
um so
you know yeah yeah it was summertime it
was like 2009
2010. um summertime
hot i was hot as hell
and uh you know i see my victim
some guy from from sgv somewhere
um me and my my criminal
the one i was going to do it with uh
we see him uh getting out of work
because he worked at the program office
you know like
typing stuff out and uh
and so uh
we uh he when he's about to go inside
the building
in the prison yard uh this we just start
attacking him you know and uh
i remember feeling tired i remember uh
while i was uh when we were stabbing him
like i remember like
like thinking like man where where the
[ __ ] is the cops at right
why haven't they rang the alarm yet you
know
uh why haven't they rang your alarm i
was so tired i remember sweating and
just
tired as hell and uh i was like
wondering like
it shouldn't take this long for the
alarms to sound you know
and uh it finally sounds and uh i still
can't stop until i get sprayed you know
so i see these
this the correction officers running
towards me
they were never about to spray me like i
don't try to throw the
the shank the prison shank right right
you throw it anyways i get perish
straight
this guy he gets stabbed 37 times
uh i go to segre after that they send me
to
the hall of course then i go to uh
segregated housing unit for for three
years
for three years
and so for three years i was going to
sell by myself
i'll go to yard my yard was a
cage like a dog kennel cage right um
a little smarter than myself just enough
so i could
pace back and forth like maybe like
three steps this way
you know probably like nine steps that
way i don't know it was it was small
right
anyways we're we're all going to yarn so
um
so i'm just there and uh for three years
reading that's all i did read books
three books and watch it over the tv
um i got released
i get released from from secret housing
you know i go back to gp
um my last two years i uh
in prison i started doing drugs i don't
know why i was like so close to my
release they were so close and
i started doing drugs i started uh doing
heroin
heroin and crystal in prison and uh
[Music]
and in prison like you're either gonna
you're gonna eat or you're gonna do
drugs you can't do both you know
so uh so i was getting myself in debt
getting myself in debt and then that and
uh as a southern hispanic i can't
buy drugs from any other race right i
could buy drugs from from white people
but
not from a black not from you know it's
very racial
and so but i'm not giving a [ __ ] i'm not
giving a [ __ ] i'm buying drugs for
whoever sells it to me right
and uh i'm like
so close to going home and i'm because
the whole time in prison i had lived my
life in prison
not thinking about my real estate you
know like i was just doing it as
as if i didn't have a release date so
thinking back now i'm like wow
okay i can't i don't think i'd be able
to do that [ __ ] again
but um anyways i racked up like a 700
debt
and uh in prison that's that's a lot of
money you know especially if you're
owing
all types of races now your own people
want to get you you know
because you're breaking the rules so
i'll be at yard
a year left in my present term my 12
year prison term
and i remember like having a you know a
every day before going to yard i'll put
a [ __ ] knife up my ass
and go to the yard and go to the pits
and pretend like i'm taking a piss
look up at the tower make sure she's not
looking at me pull that [ __ ] out
and tie it up to my my shorts my
drawstring
and i remember being like walking around
the track in prison
and looking at my people right the
southern hispanics and thinking like
which one of those is gonna be the one
to to get me for
for you know for doing what i was doing
but um
you know thank goodness nothing came out
of that i had a my
my sally actually he helped me pay uh
hey
pay uh paid a debt like like the day i
went
the day before i got released yeah the
day before because i was
because i told him like hey i owe this
money and i didn't wanna
i didn't wanna leave the prison yard
like feeling like i had to sneak away
like like a weasel you know like
i had a debt and i couldn't pay it but i
was going to try you know
and so i'm by telling
about it and and he's you know he's in
prison he he does his little
hustles in prison so he had money he uh
he pays my debt you know the day before
i got released
so um
i i'm you know i walk out the cell like
not feeling because who knows i could
have came back you know i was gonna get
out
there's no telling i could come back and
well i still got all that money you know
anyway so i i get released and uh
and i start my my new life
out here and uh in the streets again uh
the last time i had been out here was
when i was now i'm 31 not knowing what
the [ __ ] to do my both my parents are
dead
uh my brother's down in san diego
um so what can i do right
ah i have no work history
i never had a job in my life other than
the little prison ones i had
no one's in prison i mean um
so it's it was a struggle right
[Music]
the only thing i could do is sell drugs
you know i'm not trying to do no more
robberies they gave me 12 years on the
first one
you know so i see
selling drugs is
like less of a risk less risky you know
do less time if i get calm
so i was uh
that's how i was surviving from for the
first year i i was out
until like until i get arrested i get
arrested a year after a year later after
i get released
and uh they gave me four years for for a
firearm
and having a possession of control
substance uh crystal
crystal meth so now i'm in my second
prison term
i'm 32 years old i have to do four years
and i'm like like you know like i'm back
in prison you know
a place that i didn't think i was gonna
come back to
um i go to prison and
i was in calipatria my first month there
like i had done 12 years and yeah i i
see a lot of people get
stabbed and stuff like that beat up but
like
other than probably two people that
actually got killed
in my in the 12 years that i did like
that i seen actually they actually see
two people get killed in this prison
this prison i was in in cala petra
my first month there some guy died some
guy gets stabbed to this right
and they don't put us locked down they
they
resume program like a few days later and
like the following week another guy dies
and i'm thinking like all right i've
only been here like
a month month and a half and two people
are here to die like
where the [ __ ] am i at right like i'm
i'm only got i only got four years to do
like
you know but but i'm uh but i'm
but i believe in this [ __ ] though you
know i i
i've sacrificed a lot for you know
for this so but it's something as is
i think about it though you know and so
and in those yards like you everybody
participates you know
there's no like oh i'm i'll pass you
know
nah you have to you're there you have to
participate
so i'm there i'm just
trying to lay low for the most part
nothing much happens like
that was to think about that was like
the most violent prison
i had been to like everywhere and i've
been to like
nine different prisons that was like the
most violent one um
[Music]
i've been out from from that term for my
second term i've
already been out
six months seven months
and so now i'm just i'm just out here
trying to survive you know so you've
been out a while now
like almost almost a year like not not
quite
yet you know
you still have contact with your gang uh
yeah that's that's
that's the only family i have you know
that's
those are it was the only
family i had like there's i had no other
family you know
and you know there are a few not a lot
allowed and so i
i hold on to that you know
you know i'm i'm 35 years old and
i'm walking around bald headed with
tattoos everywhere like
like still you know i'm not saying i'm
i'm out there gangbang but i still
represent who i am you know
because that's all i have that's all i
have
ah i have nothing else
do you regret do you regret taking that
direction
in life years ago i mean
if i could do it all over again
i would i would do some things different
um
you know but
there weren't a lot of options for you
for that neighborhood
yeah yeah there's no option
there's no doctor lawyer role models
like that at all
like uh you know and me as a dropout
there was a but you know so
i just i joined the street gang
now i'm 35 years old thinking like [ __ ]
like is this is
this it you know um
but i love it though like i love it i
wouldn't i wouldn't trade
this for anything like
you know i would have trade this [ __ ]
for nothing i'd rather be out here
[ __ ] and skid row than
in prison anything you know
um so i'm grateful for that
yeah and you have no kids
uh i actually have my first my first uh
uh i have one one a son he's he's a
newborn
oh really yeah he's a newborn um
i uh
not not really i haven't been like i
tried but i have been like a
cps uh child child protective uh they
took the kid
because my mind the mother of my my baby
uh
she got caught you know she she tested
dirty when she gave birth she was
she she was under the influence of drugs
you know so they took the baby
um and
so it's been tough
and you know there's no there's no way
like whereas
right now i i can't you know i can't
i can't get my baby back right now the
way i'm living like i don't have you
know
so
yeah i know he's safe i know he's
he's good it's just
it's just uh it's just
if if i do have any regrets is that you
know
not being there for my for my son
as i should be you know it's
[Music]
fills me with shame like you know even
my parents my parents were drunks
they were drunks alcoholics
but
they you know they
when i needed them they were there you
know
when i needed them and to think that i
can't do that for my
son it's tough
are you using yeah currently which one
man i'm doing it all man i'm
cocaine crystal uh
pcp a little bit of heroin
a little bit i really don't like that
high
um but uh
it's uh at first i used to i used to do
drugs because it felt good and
it was fun you know now i
i do drugs just to
just to
[Music]
not feel you know
just like like
who cares you know it could be worse you
know um
[Music]
so yeah it helps you know
it's cold out there it's you know it's
it's cold out there at night
and you know see doing a little bit of
mess
slamming a little bit of mess warms me
up you know it really does it makes me
sweat
you know at three in the morning i'm
sweating you know
because it's cold out there you know
[Music]
i'm a good worker i found out i'm good
at work
i like working but
i can't get i can't get hired anywhere
[Music]
all right sergio well thank you so much
for coming in and talking
you